Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a ton of time on
this because we're going to be covering it live
tonight. But one of the things that is expected
to be shown tonight at what is as of now the
last January six committee hearing are videos
of Trump trying to record that bizarre speech
to the rioters right after the January 6th riots.
And outtakes will be published tonight during the
hearing, which will show Donald Trump struggling
through his post riot speech. The report is that
Trump was visibly struggling with what to say, not
wanting to say certain things, clearly trying to
deliver a recorded video about the riots that
would not make Trump look like he was happy
about the violence, which it sort of seems
like he was, but also would not anger and
isolate or alienate his supporters. And those are
expected to be shown tonight. Here's a little bit
of a preview of that from last night on CNN.
Speaker 3: Jeffrey, the January six committee
has snippets of outtakes from Trump's
taped message the day after the riot.
Listen to what this is, what Congressman
Adam Schiff told me about it tonight. Watch.
There are people urging him to say things to try
to get the the rioters, the attackers to go home.
There are things that they that he
can't be prevailed upon to do and say,
not for hours and hours. And and then ultimately,
when he does give a statement. Still things he
wouldn't say. And so you'll have to wait until
tomorrow evening to see precisely what that is.
Speaker 1: We are going to be covering
that live tonight on YouTube, Twitch and
Facebook. I hope that you will join me. I
don't have more to say about it right now.
We'll let those snippets speak for themselves
tonight. Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.